johana trota a lo largo de un camino
recto para 0 menor o igual que te menor
igual que 40 la velocidad de johana está
dada por la ecuación diferencial v
algunos valores de vedette en donde t
está dado en minutos y verde tm está
dado en metros por minuto se muestran en
la siguiente tabla y aquí tenemos esta
tabla inciso a usa los datos de la tabla
para estimar el valor de prima de 16 y
observa no me piden el valor debe de 16
me pidan el valor de prima de 16 ya que
en la tabla no tengo el valor de 16
mucho menos el de prima de 16 entonces
cómo podemos resolver esto sólo para
recordar esto que tenemos aquí es la
tasa de cambio de b con respecto al
tiempo evaluada en el tiempo de igual a
16 así que podemos estimar la y de hecho
esa es la palabra clave
lo que vamos a hacer es estimar de prima
de 16 y como podemos estimar este valor
bueno pues lo que vamos a hacer y de
hecho por eso voy a poner aquí que es
aproximadamente aproximadamente porque
ahora voy a pensar en cuál es el cambio
de la velocidad entre el cambio del
tiempo cerca de 16 y si vemos por aquí
no nos dan 2016 pero nos dan cuánto
valen 2012 2012 y 2020 así que vamos a
ocuparlo el cambio en la velocidad va a
ser de de 20 menos de 12 ok esto lo
vamos a dividir entre un cambio en el
tiempo que va a ser justo este 20 menos
12 y esto me va a dar bueno
aquí tengo que ver de 20 es lo mismo que
240 240
menos de 2 cm que me dicen que es 200 y
está dividido entre 20 menos 12 20 menos
12 y bueno esto me va a quedar 40 40
entre 8 o lo que es lo mismo 5 y ya
hemos acabado es por eso que es muy
bueno poner unidades ya que esto es que
tanto cambia la velocidad con respecto
al tiempo entonces las unidades serán
metros sobre minutos sobre minutos lo
cual nos va a dar metros metros sobre
minuto al cuadrado y bueno si quieres
entender un poco más todo lo que
acabamos de hacer qué te parece si ahora
resolvemos el mismo problema pero de una
manera visual ojo esto no lo tienes que
hacer en el examen pero nos servirán a
que tengas más intuición sobre lo que
está pasando en este problema qué te
parece si intentamos graficar todos
estos puntos bien pues vamos a hacerlo y
para eso
voy a bajar un poco la pantalla para que
podamos hacer una gráfica por aquí así
que me voy a tomar observa que el tiempo
siempre nos da valores positivos así que
voy a suponer que este es mi eje
que en este caso va a ser un eje del
tiempo y este va a ser mi
este va a ser mi eje y que en este caso
va a servir
dt muy bien y ahora observan btt toma
valores entre 0
y bueno aquí el más grandes 240 o el más
pequeño es menos 220 entonces vamos a
hacer una escala de m qué te parece de
300 a menos 300 así que si aquí tenemos
a 300 por aquí voy a decir que tengo a
200 y por aquí voy a decir que tengo a
100 por aquí voy a tomarme a menos 300 a
menos 300 y entonces por aquí voy a
tener a menos 200 y al menos 100 bien y
observa que el tiempo va desde 0 hasta
40 así que sí supongo que aquí es el
valor de 40 muy bien entonces a la mitad
a la mitad es el valor de 20 por aquí
tengo el valor de 10 y por aquí tengo el
valor de 30 entonces aquí tengo 30 aquí
tengo 20 y aquí tengo 10 y ahora sí
vamos a poner estos puntos y para eso
voy a cambiar de color observa que el
primer punto que me dan es el 0,0
estamos justo aquí y después dicen
cuándo
toma el valor de 12 vete te toma el
valor de 200 así que 12 está como por
aquí vd te toma el valor de 200
estamos justo por aquí muy bien después
dicen cuando te toma el valor de 20
desde te toma el valor de 240 así que
ten el tiempo es 20 y pdte es 240
estamos como por aquí después dice que
cuando el tiempo vale 24 btt vale menos
220 eso quiere decir que cambio de
dirección cuando el tiempo vale 24 que
estamos más o menos por aquí cambiamos
de dirección a menos 220 que es más o
menos por aquí de lujo y por último nos
dicen que cuando te vale 40 btt vale 150
cuando el tiempo es de 40 btt es de 150
así que estamos por aquí y si observas
estos son los puntos que me dan la
función velocidad pero lo que nosotros
queremos encontrar primero es el tiempo
te iguala 16 que está como por aquí y
ahora lo que nosotros queremos saber es
cuánto vale de prima de 16 cuando es la
tasa de cambio ahora observa que no
sabemos cuánto vale en vez de 16 pero lo
que podemos hacer y esto esencialmente
es lo que hicimos en este problema lo
que vamos a hacer es aproximar o estimar
a una función que se parezca justo
esta recta que tengo aquí es decir a la
recta entre estos dos puntos y de esta
recta vamos a tomar la pendiente porque
queremos b prima de 16 b prima de 16
será aproximadamente la pendiente de
esta recta porque al final esto es lo
mejor que podemos hacer con los datos
que nos dan con esto vamos a estimar el
valor de prima de 16 entonces lo que
literalmente hicimos fue primero
calcular el cambio en tiempo que fue más
o menos este este fue nuestro cambio en
yen es decir el cambio en la velocidad
ya eso lo dividimos entre la diferencia
o el cambio en el tiempo que es justo
este de aquí es decir el cambio en el
tiempo y así obtuvimos la pendiente de
esta recta que al final es la mejor
aproximación para la derivada cuando te
vale 16